like I want to have a voice in this
partnership I want to have a voice in
this marriage and I want to be heard and
I want to be seen and submission is like
he's your boss so your boss can take
your opinion into account but at the end
of the day Here's the final say and men
don't they don't feel like they're
respected if you don't give them the
final say like they don't want a woman
that they have to argue with all the
time but you don't have to argue with a
man to get your point across if you're
with a loving respectful man who hears
you and values you he's always going to
listen to you he can hear you and listen
to you and still tell you no